thank you prime minister excellencies
ladies and gentlemen i add my voice of
thanks to the cambodian government for
hosting this meeting and for their
considerable efforts in preparing for a
successful summit
indeed for more than 25 years the asia
europe meeting has been the most
comprehensive partnership between asia
and europe
it has helped us tackle some of the big
challenges of the day
now in the years to come
this partnership will be even more
important to recover from the pandemic
together we need to rebuild a more
sustainable and equitable world and we
need to strengthen multilateralism
because asia and europe are closely
connected
and together we have a significant
weight in the world just look at the
numbers
trade for example between europe and
asia is higher
than between any other regions in the
world
europe is the biggest investor in asia
as asem partners we represent 55 of
global trade
60 percent of the global population
and 65
of the global gross domestic product
both of our regions benefit enormously
from each other
this summit is an opportunity to
strengthen cooperation on issues that
matter
for the prosperity and security of both
our regions and beyond
so i look forward to the discussion over
the next two days
the european union will always stand up
for the rules-based international system
and asem is a key building block in this
respect
at the same time
we see cooperation beyond the
geopolitical divides
this is the baseline for our engagement
in the indo-pacific
it is this spirit that the european
union brings to this azim 13 summit
i hope we can all leave this gathering
with a renewed commitment to our
partnership thank you